poi sono nè studenti oggi altro
esperimento incredibile con totò
cornelli sport open oggi fa riferimento
molto interessante sull'eletto
dinamicità e le tosta la sua elettricità
da streller stralcio e posizionare su
manica di camicie di totoro prendere
penna e strofinare forte forte sul
braccio diventare elettrostatica e
attirare polistirolo penna adesso
elettro stato adesso totore scrivere con
medesima bella pausa che per me però vi
presento un pelo scorsa però fa niente
penda neanche ha persi trattare oggi qui
ingredienti ma l'esperimento avere un
sacco di led servirà a niente perché
tutto passava 14 limoni pochi soldi
rimasti dall'acquisto di elezioni e per
ultimo caf il dottore non sapere bene
come chiamarci usare per partita di
essere intelligenti pelle è il coltello
brenda era limone creare incisione su
ogni limone per poter inserire moneta
successivamente
[Musica]
adesso totò inserire monete rimaste
all'interno di incisione di limone
[Musica]
adesso inserire chiodi sempre i limoni
attaccare moneta a kyoto ogni volta
diverso quindi collegare limoni tra di
loro
[Musica]
9 adesso rimasto con un chiodo è una
moneta quindi attaccare ultimi cavi alla
fine di rim o no una volta che cavi
collegati a dottore mancare solamente
tentativo finale di esperimento dottore
poi con l'estremità sinistra di cavo
elettrico uno dei miliardi di lag che
completi da torre e collegare con mano
destra al proprio prima di fare dottore
dover spegnere luci fa che sono
esperimento non vedersi i sapienti
spegneranno certi casi anche sotto rete
save finale di esperimento in file cioè
dopo è creato energia totale create
energia mediante utilizzo di limoni se
quello nei quattro limoni per accendere
questa cosina dottore necessità reali in
120mila limoni per accendere telefono
quindi totò ricreare powerman
esperimento insicuro che ha utilizzato
due tipi di metallo diversi che metalli
di mamme cioè la manetta sincro cerchio
quando metalli inseriti i limoni quindi
in funzione acida scambiarsi
elettroniche generarsi corrente
elettrica cioè accendere lampadine
troppo e come imbatterete dottor a
concludere video ragazzi sperando che
sia piaciuto e come al solito iscriversi
al canale dittatore per altri
esperimenti incarichi ci vediamo alle
persone bisogno
[Musica]